so i'm pleased to introduce ben lintner
today uh he's
someone who works not too far away from
us down in new jersey at rutgers and
we're finally getting up here to give a
talk
ben did his his phd at uc berkeley
working on a trace gas transport in the
atmosphere
and spent a few years as a postdoc and
then a research scientist at ucla
before moving to his faculty position at
rutgers and he works on a really broad
range of topics you'll get a small
selection of that today
in this talk on the south pacific
convergence zone but but i really wanted
to emphasize that he's done work on
trace gas transports i noticed on a cv
there's a sort of a 2014 paper on inter
hemispheric contrasts in the hydroxyl
radical
so going you know all the way from uh
detailed chemistry to large-scale
climate dynamics uh and and a lot of
very uh societally relevant work on on
land surfaces soil moisture
precipitation and how they all interact
with each other so
ben it's all yours yeah don't don't ask
me any questions about the chemistry and
the
paper since i had such a small part in
it but
uh yeah so you know thanks for having me
up here uh bill bill had actually
invited me to come uh in the spring
and uh
since i'm not a meteorologist by
training i looked at the weather
forecasts and it was calling for snow
and
you know kind of freaked out
and it turned out to be a nice sunny day
both here in new haven and back in new
jersey
so you can blame blame the
meteorologists but anyway i picked a
nice time to come up in the fall
so what i want to talk to you to about
today is some work that i've been doing
i i mostly my student
matt nisnick
has been doing some work on the south
pacific convergence zone so i'll explain
what the south pacific convergence zone
is
and i want to talk a little bit about
i think maybe the title that i gave here
slightly different than the one
advertised but
this is a talk about variability in the
south pacific convergence zone in
particular on sort of high frequency
synoptic time scales and then maybe if i
have some
time at the end talk a little bit about
biases and models that are kind of
relevant here and and i'll kind of
allude to some of those as well in the
talk
so again matt and his nick my my phd
student is mostly responsible for the
results that i'll talk about today
hopefully i'll get a little time to show
you some results from another student
max pike
who's been doing some work on
self-organizing maps
so
you know i just wanted to lead off with
a nice pretty picture uh you know this
this is a photograph that i took from a
airline flight uh between new zealand
and new caledonia just looking at the
nice cloudscape in the southwest pacific
you know one of the nice things about
studying the southern hemisphere is that
you get to go
to the southern hemisphere because
that's where some conferences are so
that was the opportunity i had here
so this is kind of in the vicinity of of
the feature that i'm talking about today
so that that picture was taken somewhere
in here here's new caledonia the south
pacific convergence zone is this area
this very large area you can see here
australia for comparison
large area of rainfall this is a
rainfall scale that extends all the way
from kind of the maritime continent
western pacific warm pool region along
the equator you know well across the
pacific uh into
uh
mid-latitudes and it starts to die out
in mid-latitudes but it's it's really an
impressive feature in terms of its
overall scale
and you know from the perspective of
northern hemisphere we often don't talk
much about the southern hemisphere so
it's kind of an interesting place to
study
so i'm going to focus a lot today on the
synoptic interplay of circulation
moisture and precipitation along the spc
as kind of
understanding how how it varies
in observations reanalysis and a current
suite of models that you're probably
familiar with the cmip5 models
then some hopefully some preliminary
results that we've been doing looking at
daily precipitation in the spcc region
using an interesting tool
self-organizing maps and probably won't
get too much time to talk about the last
topic here
just to give you an overall sense of the
the geography and climate in the south
pacific uh
so here's the south pacific convergence
zone and then some of the other climatic
features you know high pressure
system off or high quasi steady high
pressure off the coast of australia
trade winds blowing into the spc from uh
the east
up here is the warm pool you get in
southern hemisphere summer our winter
monsoon circulation that develops uh
over over the maritime continent
extending down into australia high
pressure up here in the
north pacific there's hawaii in the
trade winds coming in like this and of
course the inter-tropical convergence
zone to the north of the equator
um
and also you know
that this is a big ocean region but lots
of little island nations uh exist here
and of course if you're living on those
island nations uh you might have to deal
with things like flooding so this was a
particularly uh
disastrous time in fiji in 2012 both in
january and april which i'm showing here
uh the island
experienced pretty significant flooding
so you know the spc as kind of the the
one of the main drivers of climate in
this region
certainly from the context of extreme
events we kind of want to know a bit
more about it
also
you know a lot of people have looked at
the spc the south pacific convergence
zone in the context of the el nino
southern oscillation
so work by people like chris fallon for
example have shown how
the the kind of axis you know if you
remember that figure showing the the
sort of diagonal tilt to the spc the
axis of the spc kind of varies in
response to uh
el nino conditions so during el nino
events it tends to be shifted a bit uh
closer to the equator during la nina or
in so cool phase conditions tends to
shift in the opposite direction and then
this study in 2012 by when jukai at all
kind of documented a sort of extreme
case in which the spc
essentially becomes zonal uh it in some
sense collapses the spc convection
collapses and kind of merges with the
itcz and this these kind of zonal what
they call zonal spcc events are very
significant in terms of the climate of
the the south pacific uh you know you're
basically replacing a double convection
zone with with a single convection zone
and that has important implications for
the climate
this is a
december january february phenomenon the
spcz is present
all throughout the year but it's most
intense in southern southern hemisphere
summer so djf
i guess i'm just trying to understand
the diagonal
this is this is a principle component
analysis i think it's for dj f uh so
it's basically showing
uh i don't even remember what this is
principal component maybe of olr
probably uh but it's basically showing
the contrast between the spc and the the
enso region up here but the point was
more to say that the you know there is
this correspondence that when we have el
nino conditions the spc responds to them
uh and then under certain kinds of
conditions not
related to the intensity of enso events
you know you might you might actually
get a a kind of collapse of the spc
convection this is meant to represent
the axis of the spcc that it becomes
more or less zonal during these extreme
events
so just in terms of you know some of the
background about the spc you know from a
from
kind of the fundamental point of view
we're interested in how the spc is
generated and how is it maintained you
know so
why is it there and in particular you
know question that i'm very that that
sort of intrigued me initially about
this is you know why does it have the
sort of distinct spatial characteristics
that we see so in contrast to the itcz
uh in the pacific esp cz has this
characteristic diagonal tilt we also see
other features kind of analogous to the
spc in the atlantic the sacz
and sort of smaller
sicz in the indian ocean and they're
sort of dynamical similarities between
all of those features but then important
differences so the spcz is of course
mostly over the ocean the sacz is
anchored to the the continent of south
america so there's kind of interesting
analogies i think to be drawn between
these different phenomena
ken takahashi and david batisti kind of
looked into this in a nice paper back in
the mid-2000s where they were kind of
looking at this fundamental question
about spc genesis and they basically
identified two kinds of paradigms or two
paradigms that may be under that that
maybe explain the spc and they termed
them western control and eastern control
kind of based on where where the sort of
center of action of each of these
control mechanisms is so in the western
control uh the kind of theories here
going back to the work of linzen and
nigum in the 1980s work by george
coladis adrian matthews
kind of point out the connection between
the spc
and the convective heating that develops
over the western pacific warm pool so
the western control is more about you
know controlling the spc from that sort
of tropical deep conducting part in the
western pacific
where i've kind of
came into this is more in terms of this
eastern control mechanism and that's
kind of looking at the spc in terms of
the contrast between the eastern pacific
which
is relatively dry at least away from the
you know it's very dry once you get
above the boundary layer relatively cool
and the sort of air masses you know kind
of a ventilation effect with low moist
static energy air masses being injected
into the spc
uh through the trade winds and also
you know in some sense it's a very it's
a highly coupled problem so you have a
distribution of sea surface temperature
and sea surface temperature gradients
and large scale substances all of these
factors seem to conspire together to
kind of give us this feature
in terms of you know why do we care
about it well you know there's the
obvious impact side things like flooding
but also
if you run climate models you're very
familiar with biases that develop in
climate models
so in the broader pacific there are
biases like the double itcz the fact
that in the eastern part of the basin
the models tend to simulate two convecti
convection zones uh one in the northern
hemisphere one in the southern
hemisphere but in the observations we
only see one
there's also bias in terms of the
simulation of in coupled models the
simulation of sea surface temperature
with the
sort of
equatorial eastern pacific being too
cold so these these are kind of well
known uh in the eastern pacific and then
in terms of the spc we see biases that
might be linked in some sense to these
but
one which i'll show you momentarily is
that the sp spc is simulated by models
is often two zonals so it doesn't have
the right
sort of diagonal tilt
and it also tends to have convection
deep convection that penetrates too far
into the east so these are these are
sort of common
biases and this kind of gives you a
sense so this is a bit of a busy figure
but
basically the blue shading on here
represents the observational target in
this case the blue shading is the area
enclosed by a particular precipitation
iso line in this case four millimeters
per day so you can think of the blue
shaded regions as being the areas in the
tropics with relatively intense deep
convection where it's raining a lot
and then the various lines that are
plotted on here are from 11 cmip5 models
basically showing where each of those
models simulates the 4 millimeter per
day contour so if there was a perfect
match between
the distribution of deep
precipitating deep convection in the
observations and the models you
basically see all of these lines kind of
outlining the blue shaded region
so you know you can look at this as
either an optimist or a pessimist so the
optimist would say well you know the the
if you squint
put on your coarse graining glasses that
the models more or less put the deep
convection in the right places in the
tropics you get it in the western
pacific across the equatorial indian
ocean
here in the sort of amazon region
extending out into the sac but then
there's also a lot of slop uh you know
in particular in the spc which i'm
focusing on
the models
tend to make uh they they don't have
enough of the extension of the spc into
the
the mid mid latitudes and they also tend
to bring the
spc convection too far to the east and i
have another figure later i'm not sure
i'll get to it but it kind of shows this
a bit more clearly where you you kind of
see the net result of this is that the
orientation of the spcz cesius simulated
by the models tends to be much too zonal
and also you know
here
this kind of jumble of lines that's kind
of the double i tcz problem so
i've looked into that a little bit there
does seem to be some connection between
models that simulate the you know kind
of strong double itcz and some of these
biases in the spc-z but some of them are
independent so
even if you correct uh the
the biases over here that doesn't
necessarily fix what's happening over
here
so
the
basis or mostly what i'll talk about
today is spc-z variability so i already
alluded to some of this on the inner
annual time scales we have the
relationship between spcz kind of the
axis of
strongest convection in the phase of
enso
uh on people have looked at this on long
time scales showing that you know with
with sort of centennial or millennial
time scale variations in things like the
intensity of warm pool
ssts or the
ssts along the eastern pacific that that
seems to have some effect on the sort of
spatial orientation of the spc
what i want to focus on more though is
the on sort of the higher frequency part
so here i'm saying on synoptic to
intra-seasonal time scales we we see
modulation of spc-z intensity by various
phenomena equatorial waves
mid-latitude rossby waves and transients
and the madden julian oscillation kind
of on you know the intraseasonal time
scale so i want to focus a bit here on
the synoptic variability you know time
scales of a week or so
um the synoptic variability turns out to
be important uh in terms of the poleward
export of heat and moisture from the
subtropics to mid and high latitudes so
the the spc z seems to be a kind of
preferential pathway along which that
that export takes place and also you
know kind of tying this in you know
there's been a lot of interest in
so-called atmospheric river uh events in
the northern hemisphere but there are
southern hemisphere analogs of
atmospheric rivers and a lot of these
kind of develop uh sort of in the
vicinity of the spc so there's some
there seems to be some connection there
so this is just a
plot from some work by adrian matthews
back in 2012 he was interested in
connecting the sort of mjo band you know
kind of time scales between 20 and 90 or
so days
to variations in the spc z region
basically just showing if you do a power
spectrum i think this is about going
long wave radiation you do get a peak in
the
the sort of mjo band so
we've looked at this a little bit in
models models have a difficult time
simulating the mjo so
anyway
what we're going to focus on is more in
the synoptic part of of this
analysis
so i wanted to just take you back a few
years to some work this is how i
initially became interested in this
problem where we wanted to look at the
relationship between convection kind of
along the eastern edge of the what we
call the margin of the spc
uh and its relationship to the the
low-level circulation so this this time
we were thinking largely in terms of
this eastern control
mechanism so our motivation here was to
kind of test the hypothesis that
variations in the strength of the
low-level inflow if the trade winds into
the spcs are strengthened that that will
have an interaction uh
in terms of the the sort of large-scale
convective response along the sbcz so
what we did was set up a composite
analysis and here we were focusing kind
of on the the sort of outer tropics part
between 10 south and 20 south kind of in
this little yellow box
we basically looked at an index of wind
speed well we were just focusing on
zonal wind the winds are largely zonal
through that box
basically conditioning the precipitation
that's actually in the bottom panel and
the moisture in this case
column water vapor from a satellite
product ssmi
basically looking at the difference in
moisture precipitation between periods
of strong inflow i.e
you know anomalously strong easterlies
versus weak inflow
or anomalous westerlies so basically
what i'm showing you here is the
difference between weak and strong
and so what you see
of course the the wind vectors in that
box are anomalous westerly we're looking
at weak minus strong but you get this
kind of moistening signal i
unfortunately didn't draw the mean spc
position on here but basically all along
the eastern margin
of the spc you kind of see this deep
column moistening occurring and the
precipitation uh kind of follows that
basically when you have a weakened
trade wind state you basically see a
kind of development or expansion of
convection along the eastern margin of
the spc
so to put this you know maybe a cleaner
picture
i'm just showing transects here zonal uh
uh transects across some latitude band i
think this is 10 south 20 south so
basically just looking at the zonal wind
component the column water vapor and the
precipitation and so we were sort of
what where we had sort of started here
was to say well we have between the
strong and weak inflow phases we have a
relaxation of the trade winds basically
the the red is the strong case where you
have strong easterlies negative values
the blue is the weak easterly case
so the trade winds relax
we get
a kind of moistening you know and you
can think about this in terms of just
cutting off the dry advection you have
less dry air advection from the east
when the trade winds are
are not as strong
so you see kind of a bump up in the
column water vapor and then the
precipitation you know you kind of get
this expansion of spc convection off to
the east of course it looks very noisy
but this was kind of the basic model
that we had in mind but of course
you can think about this from the
perspective of cause and effect
you know we were sort of starting with
the assumption that the trades relax and
kind of the moisture and convection
respond to it but it could very well be
that you know the convection changes
and you know ultimately that's why the
the trade winds relax and it turns out
you know following up with the
subsequent analysis that i'll show but i
think that's probably the more plausible
direction
so what my my student matt uh nisnick
has done
basically carried out this kind of
analog this kind of compositing analysis
that we did in our 2008 paper but here
looking at a
state of the art reanalysis product the
climate forecast system re-analysis so
that's basically shown here in this
panel and then also interrogating this
suite of uh
coupled model inner comparison project
phase five the the current generation of
models supporting ipcc uh the fifth
assessment so basically showing the the
multi-model mem multi-model ensemble
mean
this is basically the same kind of
compositing that we did in our previous
paper and you basically see in the
climate forecast system re-analysis you
know kind of this the structure that we
had before and here i would point out
you know we saw this in our in our
earlier paper but didn't really comment
too much on it that of course these the
the changing winds in this little box
are are part of a much broader
circulation so you see this remember
this is the southern hemisphere so
cyclones spin in the opposite direction
to what you're used to so this is a
low-level cyclonic circulation
so we get kind of that low-level
cyclonic circulation interestingly you
also kind of see in the moisture field
uh this is uh i guess these are both
eight eight hundred and fifty so this is
moisture at eight hundred and fifty
milli millibars and grams per kilogram
but you kind of get this this kind of
wave wave-like structure with moistening
drying moistening drying uh and then
this is the cmit 5 multi-model ensemble
mean
and you know it i was actually surprised
at how well
the multi-model ensemble mean matches
the reanalysis of course lots of things
go into this multi-modal ensemble mean
we're averaging about 17 models you're
kind of counting on the models you know
to get sort of a signal that survives
here the models kind of have to line up
in the right way
so kind of locally they do that pretty
well but you even get some of this this
kind of upstream uh
wave-like structure uh so you know it
seems that at least uh
in first first glance that
the the models are kind of capturing
this kind of synoptic interaction that
i'll describe in more detail down here
at the bottom is the precipitation uh
response so again this is like the
previous slide that i showed where we
have during the the weekend inflow phase
we get kind of an enhancement of
precipitation uh to the east and the the
contour here actually is the
that corresponds to the four millimeter
per day line averaging over all the weak
inflow events so you kind of get you
know kind of a longer spc extending out
like this
during the week in flow phase that's the
brown contour of course it's very noisy
but you kind of get this more stubby uh
spcs where you get kind of an increase
in precipitation down here but it
doesn't extend out as far to the east
the models kind of do that
here you get a sense i think of some of
the biases in the model so you know
you get a kind of enhancement of
precipitation in the weak inflow phase
but it's more like you're just kind of
flaring up what we call this little nub
here it seems a lot more continuous over
here
and you do get some of this indication
of of kind of you know
making the spcc stubbier during the
stronger inflow phase but then maybe
also shoving some of the convection down
here
so we wanted to look at this
this
figure quality is poor uh we wanted to
look at this a little bit in terms of
the the sort of interaction you know
what's actually happening uh
kind of in a transient sense so one of
the things we've looked at here is the
composites of sea level pressure so we
basically wanted to look at sea level
pressure during either the weak inflow
phase the reduced easterly phase or the
strong inflow phase the intensified
basically just composite those events or
composite sea level pressure with
respect to those events and then i'm
going to step this back in time so i've
kind of marked out a high pressure
center and a low pressure center
for the strong inflow in blue and a low
low pressure center in a high pressure
center for the weak inflow and so let me
start at day minus five
so the low that ends up over here in the
weak inflow phase uh or the high that
ends up there in the strong inflow phase
or this one and this one and so you can
see what happens as i step forward you
know both the low and the high are
propagating uh off to the east this is a
day minus four
you know so there's a strong westerly
flow this is southern hemisphere summer
so
uh
you know
this is kind of on the the equator word
edge of the the southern hemisphere jet
and at this time of year it's weaker
than it would be in in winter but you
still get these
you still get these transient
circulations that are propagating along
day minus three you can see actually
relative to our target box that both
these uh you know both the high pressure
center here and the low pressure center
have kind of moved off to the east
and then they kind of go a little bit
retrograde uh at day minus two so
they're kind of wobbling back toward
the target box and then at day minus one
we're here and back to day zero
so you know essentially what we're we're
sort of seeing here is you get these
these events that are kind of marching
along
and out here in the the southeastern
tropical pacific just like we have in
the northern hemisphere off the coast of
california there's a very strong
high pressure center so
clockwise circulation in the northern
hemisphere counterclockwise circulation
in the southern hemisphere and so these
these
circula these these eddies or these
mid-latitude storms are kind of coming
along and then they they kind of
encounter that blocking
flow in the high pressure center there
so you know
in a sense they kind of scoot past and
then they're they're kind of entrained
back into the sort of region here that
influences the area that we were looking
at
so this is kind of the picture at the
surface
so then we wanted to see how things look
as as we move vertically
uh
so here's the composites that we did at
850 millibars as before from this the
re-analysis so we're using re-analysis
here to fill in the gaps that we don't
have because you know limited
observations
this is the multi-model ensemble mean
from cmip also at 850.
so you can see what happens is we go up
to 700 we basically have a very similar
structure you have this low-level
cyclonic circulation
the enhancement of moisture along the
eastern margin of the spc and this
wave-like pattern behind it
you see that at 700 millibars
it also seems to be present at 500
millibars and there's even some
indication of it all the way up at 250
but they're the particularly in terms of
the moisture structure the anomalies are
getting very small so it's kind of hard
to make out on this common color scale
so what this suggests is that we have a
pretty deep structure
that has both the surface component but
then also this kind of structure uh up
through at least the mid troposphere and
when we look at the cmip5 models
we see a roughly comparable structure
and again
within
you know
the the sort of uncertainties with
averaging together all of these models
that may have their own sort of spatial
biases it's actually sort of surprising
to me at least that we we still have
these fairly coherent structures as we
move up
uh into the troposphere
so we looked a little bit in terms of
you know we actually want to understand
this interaction you know
we're basically seeing in the weak
inflow phase
we developed this this uh cyclonic
circulation so how does that actually
affect the moisture because you might
think about the moisture feeding into
the deep convection
and so what we what we did was to look
at composites of moisture anomalies now
this is done at different vertical
levels i don't think i have the labels
on here but 850 700 500 and 250 maybe
well maybe i'm off but oh no sorry these
are the lag plots uh
each of the two colors on here that's it
the the two colors represent different
pressure levels so red is 850 millibars
so that's kind of the low level
moistening and then blue uh is 500
millibars kind of mid-tropospheric level
and then these are stepping through
times so day zero is here uh day minus
two here and day plus two here so you
know at the day zero just as a reference
uh and this again is in cfsr and the
multi model ensemble mean over here
we kind of get uh
red at 850 so you kind of get this low
level
moistening kind of in a you know
kind of along the the diagonal of the
mean spc we see that in the multi
multi-model ensemble mean kind of above
that at 500 millibars
co-located with that that strong
moisture anomaly at the surface these
are the differences between weak and
strong so we're seeing positive here
relatively positive during the week
phase so moisture conditions during the
weekend flow phase
and then
at at low levels we we kind of see some
of that wave uh like structure maybe not
as much at 500 millibars but what's
interesting is going back uh in time so
this is kind of two days before the sort
of peak of of
either the strong uh
in the strong or weak inflow we kind of
get this this moistening that's
occurring and you'll notice that most of
the moistening maybe we see it a little
bit better in the models but that that
moistening tendency kind of in the
vicinity of this box is sort of stronger
at the upper levels at 500 millibars
than it is closer to the surface so it
kind of suggests at least to me that we
we get some in advance of of these kind
of perturbation these transients coming
into the spc-z region that they kind of
are generating a bit of moistening
at mid levels and that might be
especially important in this region
remember we're kind of on the margin
uh between strong convection to the the
west and southwest and relatively dry or
inhospitable conditions to the the east
or northeast and so you know kind of
pumping up the moisture in the mid
levels
might might be important to kind of
prime the environment there to support
deep convection
previous she was suggested
whatever that thing is it was infected
right
now
it was kind of
crazy like maybe a wave
i think it's probably it
i think it's probably a mixture of the
two and that's one of the struggles i
think with doing these types of of
analyses is that it's it's hard to tease
apart what's forcing what
uh so i think there is some there is
some kind of ins in situ response there
that's
you know and some of the theory that's
been kind of developed to explain this
sort of says that
these waves come in and because of the
sort of local characteristics there that
they're sort of exciting a local
convective response
but i agree it's it
you know i think there's sort of
consistency in these pictures but it's
not like a clean
it's not a clean separation
so we just wanted to look a little bit
at the
sort of upstream characteristics so this
is doing a composite analysis now over
250 millibar winds but looking three to
five days out from uh
either a strong inflow event or a weak
inflow event
and looking in particular
uh at the upper level winds because of
course these these anomalies you can
imagine that they're riding along the
axis of the
southern hemisphere jet
uh and you do see
you know it's again it's not like a
a
kind of
slam dunk but we do see some differences
kind of in the the upstream structure of
the jet so during the week inflow phase
if you kind of look over here
we seem to have a stronger
jet uh maximum to the south of australia
and that interestingly about the
southern hemisphere jet is you kind of
get this bifurcation where you get sort
of a pathway to the south
and then also as a secondary pathway to
the north and that in the weak inflow
phase that that northern pathway may be
is a bit stronger than what we get in
the strong inflow phase so to kind of
tie this in and some nice work has been
done uh by by both adrian matthews and
matt witlansky
they kind of talk about the spc you know
the convection flaring up here in
response to uh
transients that basically are fed into
you know transients moving along this
mean flow and then getting steered into
the spc region so
the weak inflow phase
upstream of weak inflow events we maybe
see a sort of large-scale
structure that's more conducive to
ultimately steering those uh those
transients that are being spawned uh
into the spcc region
so our kind of picture based on this
analysis was to you know basically
suggest different elements that we have
you know a storm track
in the weak inflow phase sorry
strong strong and weak in the weekend
flow phase we maybe have a storm track
that that tends to preferentially uh
move uh these these transient eddies
into the spc-z region
in terms of sort of the the pressure
structures you know we have an anomalous
cyclone that develops maybe as a
response to these transient events
coming into the spcc region but also
because the convection is highly
interactive
you know we can't really separate that
cleanly but we do you know kind of
suggest that we have this this sort of
uh upper level influence so what i was
initially thinking in terms of the low
level
modulation of the trade winds i now kind
of think that's that that's more
response to just this upper level
forcing then sets up this convection
and the sort of low-level circulation as
a feedback
on to that
so i just wanted to talk a little bit a
bit more about the spcc storm
interaction so this is some
follow-up work that that we submitted
with adrian matthews and matt matt
widlansky this past summer
and that's basically
building on some ideas so adrian uh
proposed in his 2012 paper that we we
should really think about the spc as as
being sort of the sum of events or
pulses of convective activity
i'm not quite sure how much i you know i
think there's some merit to that
argument although you know when i look
at the spc and in satellite images you
know of various things
it seems to be pretty persistent so you
know there's often convection there now
sometimes it's more intense other times
it's less intense so it might be that
the spc is more or less there but you
get kind of these
flare-ups of convection depending on
what's interacting with it
matt woodlansky who was a phd student
with peter webster
looked a bit into the the kind of
interaction so i mentioned the kind of
storm the sort of preferential uh
steering of uh mid-latitude eddies into
the spc z region under
certain conditions so matt widlansky
looked a bit at that
and identified this region which i'm
showing here the so-called storm
graveyard i guess it's appropriate that
we're a couple of days from halloween
talking about the storm graveyard which
is basically a region of negative zonal
stretching deformation that's basically
where d-u-d-x
becomes negative and that
you know in terms of simple kind of ray
tracing uh theory
you can basically show that that that
would correspond to increasing the
refractive index of the mean flow the
the waves experience as they're moving
along that increase in refractive index
causes the sort of
equator word deflection of these uh
eddies so
somehow this this uh
storm graveyard seems to be important in
setting up this steering pathway into
the spc
so we looked a bit at this storm
graveyard in the context of the cmip 5
models
and the basic upshot is the you know we
can look at the multi-model ensemble
mean that's the one down here so the the
dash contours are the observed uh and i
for these these i guess are are
d-u-d-x values so the dash contours are
are you know
iso lines of dudx and the blue shading
is
kind of comparable iso lines uh but from
the multi-model ensemble mean
so what what seems to emerge here is
that the
multi-modal ensemble mean has a weaker
storm graveyard so the sort of minimum
dudx values are higher
uh less negative and also the the sort
of center of the storm graveyard is
maybe displaced a bit to the northeast
so this you know
if if we have this kind of background uh
storm graveyard kind of influencing
where the interaction between the storms
and the spc takes place
maybe some of the the bias that we see
where the spc-z is a bit too
zonal is just because this storm
graveyard region is is displaced a bit
too close to the equator so the sort of
region in which the storms get steered
maybe kind of has an influence on the
geometry
there's a lot of variation as you might
imagine when you look across the
individual models and this kind of
points out maybe some of the danger in
doing an ensemble average you can look
at you could pick your favorite model so
i
work a lot with gfdl colleagues so
actually i don't like that one so much
uh here's the gfdl model you know you
can see that that one that one has a
storm graveyard that's much too weak and
much too equator word
other ones you know the csiro model the
australians you know
they care a lot about southern
hemisphere climate so they try to get it
right
their storm graveyard is too intense
also has that kind of spatial bias
the mpi model they actually do a pretty
good job
this is actually those are actually
results when we run the cmip or when the
cmip5 models are run with the ocean
interactive with the atmosphere sort of
both the ocean and the atmosphere being
solved by the model
we can also look at the amip style
simulations the atmospheric model inner
comparison style simulations so these
are simulations in which we feed
each of the models the observed sea
surface temperature distribution so
presumably you know any if any any sort
of bias that's being introduced because
of errors in the coupling between the
atmosphere and the ocean
uh
that at least from the oceans
perspective that's kind of taken away by
by giving the atmosphere the lower
boundary condition
and this actually does seem to clean
things up you can see here the
multi-model ensemble mean
the storm graveyard is
closer in intensity i forgot to mention
the percentage here
is kind of the percentage intensity of
the multi-model ensemble mean relative
to the maximum intensity
observed so you know it's getting closer
it's about 90 percent as strong and the
center of the
the the storm graveyard is much closer
to what we see
in the observations and the individual
models also seem to be cleaned up a bit
so the upshot here is that
giving the models the correct sea
surface temperature distribution
even though this is an upper level uh
feature
that seems to correct some of the bias
there's still quite a bit of inner model
spread both in the position and in in
the magnitude of the storm graveyard so
it's not that you know only giving the
model sea surface temperature is going
to correct these kinds of biases and we
see similar if we look at other measures
of biases in the spc
we see that so
giving the models the distribution of
sea surface temperature tends to correct
the tilt of the spc-z quite a bit you
still get biases pretty strong biases in
the amplitude of the or the the
intensity of the precipitation
so you know it's it's not that we can
completely correct things just by by
specifying the ocean
this is a bit of a busy plot but
basically we were looking at uh
we kind of wanted to do uh an
attribution analysis to do some vortex
tracking so this is just kind of a
composite analysis where instead of
doing the composites like we were doing
before now we identify uh vorticity
anomalies upper upper level vorticity
anomalies of a certain magnitude
you know basically places where we we
expect we have you know kind of this
upper level uh or mid level i think this
was mid-level uh cyclonic circulation
and then just do the compositing uh with
respect to to those anomalies so here's
day zero
this is from looking at trim i think
using the re-analysis wins to do the the
compositing
the cfsr
the atmospheric model inner comparison
project models in cmip5 and the coupled
models and so it's basically showing you
you know kind of the precipitation
response that we were seeing before
this is precipitation now not moisture
but
you know when you have this kind of
cyclonic
these cyclonic vorticities kind of in
this target region you get an increase
in precipitation to the northeast a
decrease in precipitation to the
southeast it's similar kind of structure
to what we were seeing before
and the suggestion here kind of going
back in time although it didn't turn out
i think as cleanly as we had hoped but
we can kind of track
these vortices back in time and i have a
maybe cleaner result in the next slide
but you kind of get a sense
at least going back one day
that you can kind of see see this
these kind of anomalies the vortex kind
of tracking into that region so it gives
the sense that you know these are
incipient disturbances that are spawned
outside of the spc and then propagate
into it
so this is just doing you know kind of a
crude uh vorticity tracking just kind of
looking at where a particular you know
vorticity minimum
i guess
maybe i'm getting the sign wrong but
looking at you know these cyclonic
vorticity anomalies and then just
tracking their position back i think
this was done two days before so you
know going back
the previous day and then the the next
day and just kind of showing uh within
the cfsr and the multimodal ensemble
mean
where where the various vortices that
kind of ended up in that target region
came from you can see a lot of the
the tracks are kind of from the
southwest sort of like what we would
expect these these uh
these anomalies are riding along the
southern hemisphere jet and then gets
steered into this spcc region there's a
lot of you know the models show a
general tendency for that that kind of
south uh west northeast oriented axis of
vortex motion but of course a lot of
variation as well so the the individual
model characteristics i think
you know the models are kind of
capturing this interaction maybe it's
not too surprising because the even
though their course models
they're still they still have enough
resolution that they can capture these
larger mid-latitude uh eddies
so
you know in summary
i think you know what we've shown and
what i'm fairly convinced by is that the
cement 5 models reasonably capture this
synoptic scale interplay of
circulation moisture and precipitation
along the spc
and that's despite the fact that
the models still have biases in the way
they simulate the spc so it's kind of
like you get this
you get this storm interaction that kind
of flares up the convection along the
spc or where the spcc should be
how the model actually simula you know
whether it whether it simulates
the other parts of the spc the more
tropical portion correctly i think
that's kind of a different a different
story
so my prior work coming into this was to
focus more on the low levels and the
advection of dry
relatively dry relatively low moist
static energy air into the spc but now
i'm thinking it's more
that you know you've got these
disturbances coming in at upper levels
and then through the interaction
partly through the response that we're
interested in looking at namely the
convection
that feeds back on the low-level winds
so
you know this was kind of arguing this
kind of low-level
argument was was maybe more of a
thermodynamically oriented argument
whereas this kind of upper level stuff
is more about the dynamics
i think that's all saying though that we
have to care about both the dynamics and
and the thermodynamics so when you you
get these anomalies coming in
you know a big part of the story if you
were doing a budget would would be the
effect of this low low level uh
advection of low moist static energy air
um
that's different than than doing it kind
of in the
cause and effect sort of way that we had
initially hoped
our lead lag analysis it's not as clear
as we had
hoped it would be but it does suggest
that there is we can see some upstream
uh differences in the jet exit region
near australia in the southern
hemisphere storm track that really seem
to maybe set up conditions that become
more favorable for this interaction to
occur
then some things that we're currently
working on you know we want to
do a little bit in terms of lagrangian
trajectory analysis i'm a big fan of you
know lagrangian parcel dispersion models
so kind of looking at the output from
lagrangian trajectory
lagrangian parcel model to kind of
develop climatologies of of the inflow
air masses and kind of figure out you
know
in a more lagrangian as opposed to
eulerian perspective what might be going
on
and then some idealized uh results with
an intermediate level complexity model
that i'm actually going to skip over i
had them in here but i want to show you
just a bit about the self-organizing
maps but that we can
we can with with the aid of an
intermediate level complexity model we
might be able to look a bit more into
the cause and effect because of the
simplifications
uh in in the model maybe tease apart
causality from from feedback but let me
let me skip over that
uh
we can come back to if you want but i
just wanted to briefly in the last few
minutes here talk about the work by my
other student max pike who's just just
starting out but i thought i would show
these results because they're cool this
is applying a self-organizing map
approach to analyze uh spcc region
precipitation
so just to go through this quickly our
motivation here is we have a large
amount of daily spatial data both from
the observations and certainly from the
models you know we have more data
sometimes than we can handle so how can
we what kinds of tools can we apply
to extract representative and meaningful
patterns from these data
ultimately in doing this what we hope to
do is to be able to connect whatever
patterns we might see to the
meteorological conditions so we can make
a physical you know attribution
but we can also think about using using
these just as a potential basis for
comparing models and observations so we
can compute soms self-organizing maps
from the observations
compute them from the models and see how
similar dissimilar the soms are
so the tool of course is these
self-organizing maps so what are they
it's a neural network-based approach
which consists of a lattice of
interconnected nodes i'll show
a brief picture but these nodes the kind
of outputs are shaped by whatever input
data
are put into the self-organizing map by
a
user-specified criterion or set of
criteria
and basically
there's kind of a competition you you
set up this lattice of nodes and each
node kind of competes with other nodes
basically to see which one is most
similar to a particular input datum and
the winning node the node that looks
most like the input gets adjusted
uh so that it starts to look a bit more
like the input
and actually this it's a bit more
complicated than that because
depending on how many you know the kind
of radius of influence you might
actually have multiple nodes get
adjusted but the winning node gets
adjusted the most
and ideally then what the soms do is
distill a large data set down to some
manageable number of structures that we
can interpret physically and this is you
know you can think of this in much the
same vein as what we do with a very
common approach in geophysical data
analysis which is eos we're basically
using the eos as a way of distilling you
know a large amount of data down to some
smaller number of modes
so the som lattice
looks kind of like this we've got inputs
over here which are fed into
this kind of output set of nodes each
time an input is displayed to the the
set of nodes some comparison is made
between you know it might be some
eulerian
distance metric or some generalized
distance metric that basically compares
the input to each of these outputs one
of the outputs looks most like the input
so then there's an adjustment scheme
that's applied to kind of shape the
output to the input and this is done
many times
so i won't i'll kind of skip over the
tutorial here just to kind of go ahead
to the results which i you know we're
still kind of thinking about these
uh and precisely how to interpret them
but i think they're neat so this is
taking the trim data from 1998 to 2013
during djf so basically during the time
when the spc is at its peak intensity
and this is basically the result a
set of four maps or four outputs trying
to classify the daily uh snapshots or
the daily averages of precipitation into
these four categories
so you know you get some interesting
stuff here
these two down here since i am
interested in the spcz these kind of
have very active spc convection so this
is rainfall in millimeters per day so
you get you know kind of intense
rainfall in the spc you'll notice if you
look closely and you can kind of use
these islands here as a guide
that you have the the strongest
convection kind of closer to these
islands in this group
and then it's kind of shifted away in
this group
and you might expect also when you look
up here you can see that the the kind of
dry region in the east extends further
into the western pacific here than it
does here so based on what i said
earlier about enso you know that this
seems to be the the contrast between la
nina conditions basically over here and
el nino conditions over here and in fact
you know if we
we just take now we have a small sample
of data since we're looking at trim
but three el nino or el nino-ish years
if we just use those
you know you basically can kind of see
the same overall large-scale structure
so where we have convection in the spc
you know tends to be shifted
off to the northeast
uh relative to say the la nina mode
where the convection in the spca tends
to be shifted off to the southwest so
you know in that sense the som is cool
because it it can kind of pick out this
known effect we know that there's an
enso signal in spcz region convection
what i'm more interested in is if we
kind of focus
say just on the la nina uh years when
we're sort of correcting for this
difference in the background climate la
nina and el nino years are very
different in the pacific
but you kind of get you know what we're
seeing here
two or maybe even three regimes in the
spc
where you know here the tilt of the spc
is much steeper than it is over here we
kind of see the same thing in the la
nina phase
where we have maybe a less tilted spc
regime here in a more tilted spc region
here
so what we hope to do and again you know
i'm just showing you the the raw results
here without much context but that we
can somehow
relate these uh
these kind of differences in spcc slope
to different you know sort of
meteorological conditions so
you know when you get a more tilted spc
versus a less tilted spc what does that
actually correspond to does it
correspond to something physically i
mean that's always the the key with
these data analysis approaches is that
you know at some level they're
mathematical constructs but we want to
make sure that they're physically
physically meaningful so
you know that that's a work in progress
so i think i'll i'll stop there
you